kate beckinsale and Pete Davidson they
aren't dating anymore
ETS exclusively learned the two are not
currently seeing each other a source
tells et they're still friendly but are
not on romantic terms we had our
suspicions the heat was dying down
because last week they appeared on The
Tonight Show back-to-back nights Kate on
Wednesday either an orgasm is an aid for
the sneeze or sneeze is an eighth of an
orgasm which way is it that's true and
Pete on Thursday do you not call the
basement the mancave is that no weird
some people do but no I get yeah so now
I call it the basement like the Ohio
State University and suspiciously
neither mention their relationship that
people are super interested in I mean I
saw detective Pikachu last night and now
I'm doing detective work anyway
let's recap this short-lived romance and
in memoriam if you will because it got a
heck of a lot of attention because they
like to make out who doesn't ground zero
a Golden Globes after-party in January
and I witnessed old et Pete and Kate
seemed super flirty at the Netflix party
they were on a back patio for at least
an hour giggling appear in cozy etc and
then it felt like a whirlwind they were
spotted holding hands and you know I'm
gonna bring this up again the infamous
Ranger game that launched a thousand
memes make it out while sitting next to
Krieger eyes Anthony burrows gates at a
hockey game
hockey players going at it basically
like beating the hell out of each other
and I was genuinely concerned and we
chatted the entire game she's very witty
on March 9th Pete addressed his
relationship on Saturday Night Live's a
Weekend Update with an honestly amazing
anecdote about people hating on their
age gap take it away Pete if you have
questions about a relationship with a
big age difference just asked Leonardo
DiCaprio Jason Statham Michael Douglas
Richard Gere Jeff Goldblum Scott Disick
Dane Cook Derek Jeter Bruce Willis
Harrison Ford Tommy Lee Alec Baldwin
Sean Penn and whoever the president of
France is Mel Gibson
Billy Joel mick jagger's bestest loan
Eddie Murphy Kelsey Grammer Larry King
Larry King Larry King Stewart of Donald
Trump
Pete Davidson everyone at the end of the
month can't address their media scrutiny
in an interview with the LA Times saying
quote I've never been in this position
before never dated anybody who comes
with their own bag of mischief and
they're both hot and successful and
they'll be fine that's all for now guys
I'm ash cross and if you want to chat
and I'll see you next time